peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
à
allo ota 17 10 je voudrais parler aux
acteurs brigneau il faut que je parle au
docteur lui-même madame c'est personnel
écoutez madame je ne permettrai pas de
déranger docteur en plein réveillon à
plus de minuit si ça n'était pas très
urgent merci elle a aussi vous docteur
mon nom ne vous dira rien je vous
téléphone en ce moment de chez
mademoiselle 28 et 22 rue poussin oui
mademoiselle malin watier venait tout de
suite docteur il arrivé un accident il
ya en activant merci docteur
[Musique]
allô police judiciaire passez-moi un
inspecteur et services s'il vous plaît
merci
allo ici le docteur brigneau 117 avenue
mozart je vous téléphone de chez
mademoiselle vaty 22 rue poussin nom
aura eu bat y était her une moitié la
bonne publicité ça doit déjà les gros
titres dans le matin le suicide du
réveillon la rue poussin saignée dans le
xvième il va te serais l'overdose un
quart d'heure vingt minutes c'est parti
comment vous serez partie oui c'est vrai
on est au service du docteur ayez
l'amabilité de veiller à ce qu'on ne
touche à rien et lui dit mon docteur je
peux avoir besoin de vous joindre cette
nuit où puis-je vous appelez vous voulez
vous donner votre numéro de téléphone
auteuil 17 disent merci docteur et du
vent bien que je peux vous appeler à
n'importe quelle heure de la nuit ou
suis désolé mais envers docteur et bonne
année quand même
m bon réveillon de saigner bâtir une
femelle et gaucheret pas service à
l'avouer cette nuit je vais pour
m'occuper des collègues et de la société
saint-vincent-de-paul
on a plus que chez les poulets qui se
pense que ça fait bien mais ils m'ont
même pas demandé mon avis à ceux férié
mais quand même mieux être en train de
casser la croûte chez mon frère qui est
photographe rude harriman vous savez la
boutique au coin de la rue lamarck ici
on la vitrine ya des têtes de mariées
sous verre on ne fait pas de publicité
parce que des têtes de mariée comme ça
c'est à vous dégoûter du mariage il leur
manquait le persil dans les narines
alors moi j'ai pas voulu juin de m robin
à la collection enfin console comme on
peut de fêter le nouvel an à la pj ont
marqué chacun a son idée sur la façon de
passer la saint sylvestre je pense que
vous en pensez vous mais moi en tout cas
je suis pas d'accord avec la formule
qu'ils avaient adoptée
et quatre de la joyeuse petite bande de
la rue poussin dont j'allais faire la
connaissance dans le mois d'un réveillon
à deux ou d'un réveillon à 50 ou encore
d'un réveillon tout seul avec soi-même
dans mon genre mais pas quatre comme
cela culture toujours un cadavre sur la
feuille des anneaux et dire que je broie
du noir
évidemment voilà deux verres de taureaux
qui s'adorent deux par deux c'est clair
non il n'ya qu'un malheur dans la vie
c'est le contraire de la danse legrand
distinguer bernard celui qui sert de
près la petite blonde huguette mais est
avec mona oui la fille qui danse
tendrement avec le bo philippe la
maîtresse de maison mona plutôt bac
selon l'intérieur
ah non non non bernard et mona ne sont
pas mariés lui est trop riche pour ça et
elle le mariage la gênerait
philippe et huguette non tu es sont pas
mariés mais patience ça viendra son
fiancé
[Musique]
les blues qu'est ce que c'est un show
pierre jeunet a chanté hier
ben moi j'ai soif ananas pamplemousse
orange petit régime nourrice ou ici non
c'est le régime mona je dois bien voir
scotch ou c'est pas un seul bon c'est
bon pour une raison sa tranquille
est ce qu'il faut dans la cuisine
[Musique]
magnifique de quoi voir la vie en rose
du scan l'amateur j'ai pas besoin de ça
moi pour voir la vie en rose
regardez également des sorties tous les
potins c'est vrai je mens pas non je
sais pas ce qui m'arrive
on n'a pas l'habitude d'être amoureux
quel âge as-tu 34 ans voilà
l'explication
j'ai vieilli pour du tout pas du tout je
me suis jamais senti en forme
oui tu prends des sentiments tout à
l'heure j'ai faim
qu'est ce qu'on mange du caviar si tu
veux j'en ai apporté des tonnes aux
chicanes adore ça tous voient le pain on
va faire des passes
[Musique]
l'amour
je suis heureux pas moi
fin d'année me donne le cafard est ce
qu'on va faire je chasse et un cafard
365 jours de ratages d'ennui on m'a dit
tu exagères comme toujours je porte le
deuil de l'année 57 où vas-tu chercher
des idées pareilles pense plutôt à l'an
prochain tous les deux ensemble ce sera
formidable
les années se suivent et se ressemblent
mais ça non je te jure
l'année prochaine tu verras elle sera
merveilleuse tu parles comme dans les
romans que ligue est tu avais pas de moi
jamais personne ne t'as aimé comme je
t'aime attention
[Musique]
ah non alors tout ce qu'il a eu à vence
c'était quoi je vous rendre jaloux
bernard laisse pas ton esprit commencent
à souffrir mais tu t'es amusé à me faire
marcher
c'était si drôle car ce n'est qu'une
seule petite garce philips d'un prix
bien sûr ça me déplaît contrainte de
gars qui n'en a pas l'habitude 1 et
pourtant une petite gare c'est tout ce
que tu es c'est trop facile de prendre
un gars gentil l imbécile comme moi qui
tu aimes à en crever et de le faire
marcher mais ça tue le père a été
entendu mais je me fous de ce que les
autres paiements tort tu m'amuses
rapatrier si j'en ai envie
sadi dans ton cher petit philippe club y
attacher à petit mana qui sont un peu
bruyant d'une pauvre femme viala c'est
leur droit
leur droit absolu ils ont tant de choses
importantes à ce dès qu'est ce que tu
insinues disais tout ça m'est
complètement indifférent un mot n'admet
plus rien mais toi toi qui aimes dans
ton chien petit philippe ça ne te gêne
pas ce manque de discrétion absolue
mental que l'esprit large et toi tu es
très gentil de prendre soin de mon
bonheur le bonheur
non moi je le trouve le bonheur
incompatible avec la fabrication des
chaussures et philippe et gauthier au
paquet de luxe et son luxe s'arrête à
ses bottines pour le reste il est il est
vulgaire un peu mufle
moi je préfère les muscles comme lui
vous soit disant genre que la même date
on jean coutu guette
tu sais très bien comment tout ça va se
passer philippe va te laisser tomber
voilà c'est fini il ya des tas d'autres
choses aussi qui sont finis ce que je
veux c'est vivre avec toi me tais toi
demande
personne ne peut prendre au sérieux les
déclarations d'amour avec un coureur
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse que tu
me crois que je me tue vous
je tue filet dybiona capable et
d'ailleurs je te le demande pas
j'aimerais bien que tu me demande
quelque chose
écoute bernard laisse moi mais philippe
même si c'est difficile même si mort
pousse même si nous trompent
aucun espoir aucun même t'en fais pas tu
es beau été distingués des filles qui
ramassera encore à l'appel et seulement
voilà il ya que toi qui me plaisent et
moi n'y a que philippe philippe sol et
tant qu'il sera là son dernier mot oui
mon joli zakouski pirojki du caviar
comme c'est gentil sétois bernard jeu
ici aux prises de bernard le magnifique
surprise admet d'ailleurs parole d'avoir
ce soir je suis prêt à toutes les folies
philip k ah non pas maintenant le whisky
i get avec le caviar on boit de la vodka
tous les magazines féminins le répète ça
c'est plutôt n'en dostoïevski vodka
toujours votre puis la vodka c'est
beaucoup moins rare que le ski est
beaucoup moins cher
à toi la paix
gentil bernard d'avoir fait cette folie
pour moi et c'est tout naturel alliant
philippe marini s'est enfin décidé à
répondre ne peut pas nous et nadja comme
les copains de louer on lui retient
bateau huit mois à l'avant ça lui suffit
pas qu'est ce que tu veux il est vendu
et ben on ira dans un village de toile
où et non mais non marquez unis
proposent autre chose mais non pas 12
mètres moitié parce que vous avez décidé
que nous aurions encore en croisière a
battu serait gentil de me donner
quelques détails mena est-ce que je sois
encore obligé de coucher sur le garde
manger comme il ya deux ans ils nous
font la vaisselle la chair à tour de
rôle bien alors nous voir ont de l'eau
salée à la bombe alors que ces messieurs
montrer sans les gaillards d'avant
parleront de bobines froch en essayant
de fumer la pipe qui dort dîne dont vous
faisiez pas tellement les dégoûter cette
année vous passez plutôt votre temps à
vous retire les faits son soleil comment
est il crée ce bateau il est très bien
d'ailleurs tu vas voir il m'avait et
comment il s'appelle hayate à raiatea
c'est pas mal mais tu pourras partie
aussi en tant que thème indiqué
n'exagérons rien ça va beaucoup mieux
depuis que je me prive de boire et de
fumer tue voix au minéral pas la moindre
petite entorse à l'egypte ce soir minuit
musc renault trucks l'allergie la leyre
jettent ils allaient rejette-t-il ça te
plante pas dans les détails pouvant
table que tu bois de l'alcool
naturellement c'est pour ça que j'ai
enfants me suis abstenu aujourd'hui
qu'eric un aussi mauvais état ces
dernières années je ne vais pas ménagé
ses forces est libre comme une petite
vieille jeudi dont je n'ai pas 100 ans
non bien sûr je suis pas une petite
fille monté en graine moi c'est pas moi
qui te coûter 10 à un peu moins d'un
mois un homme qui préfère une vieille
peau dans mon genre un peu de franchise
cet homme dont tu parles il est ici tu
peux le nommer par pitié par pitié on
est ici pour réveillonner gentiment pas
pour s'engueuler
en cause oui notre café lui faudrait
d'abord le débouché c'est assez juste
n'est pas mal et il a plus qu'assez de
bouchons enfin je veux complètement non
maintenant atteint il ya un couteau par
ici n'est pas mal mais bon on fait ce
bateau le comex est celui qui venait
tous les jours là cet été à camara le
petit bateau qui va pas tomber dans les
pommes non tu sais bien que j'ai horreur
de ça va ne regarde pas qui a dit oui
oui dans la salle de bain tout versé
dans l'art ma pharmacie charmante soirée
monde se fait la gueule et maintenant à
blesser dans la salle de bain oui
charmante soirée avoue bernard que tu y
est pour quelque chose
nom court tu écoutes on va pas s'y
mettront aussi un
m
pour trouver quelque chose à tous
[Musique]
il ya tout sauf du sparadrap vrai
désordre la mode à la droite à main
attends je les suis que cela recolle
[Musique]
voilà tu peux aller faire les beaux
salons mahatta temps
[Musique]
alors ces grands blessés ça va mieux et
c'est réparé
[Musique]
elle ne compte pas pour moi
à les voir danser comme ça on réseau
rêverie tous les quatre pour des petits
seins cependant l'un de ses petits seins
savait qu'il allait tenter un autre et
que sept autres ne verrait pas se lever
le premier jour de la nouvelle année
[Musique]
il a écouté leurs scènes
alors oui ils ont mis à danser tout
allait très bien mais pas besoin des
biens c'était à prendre contre ce risque
là je peux même vous dire le titre le
titre tu parles jugement foot en titre
avec tes airs de grand sportif de cinéma
tu commences à me courir le plus tôt est
le genre de type à kohler rentrée qui ne
pardonnent par les affirmations petit
amour propre
d'autant que la vie doit pas être dans
le dos avec une poupée comme la tienne
celle là
l'échantillon type de mannequin pour
vitrine de leur magasin très comestible
d'ailleurs comme estime de luxe à
déguster avec précaution les idées qu'il
ne doit pas détester les gros compte en
banque
un vrai nom puisqu'elle a refusé les
honnêtes proposition de l'autre
sûrement plan aux amateurs de croisière
doit d'avoir dans la pool philippe et
lui le ténébreux le veuf et rarement vu
un homme du monde aussi réussi dans les
moindres détails
samon adv est terriblement le gêner
si monsieur devait être avide de
changement il lui fallait de la chair
fraîche une fille sans complication pour
qu'il aurait été le grand homme
et voilà le reste tout seul pour
débrouiller cette salle est fait il
était pressé d'en finir les collègues de
l'identité judiciaire précédé expédier
leurs photos leurs marques et leurs
remarques toute leur mise en scène et
salons par des emprunts très seulement
j'ai vraiment besoin pour mon enquête
qui se fait pas encore déranger ces
messieurs danse avec leurs bourgeons
sous le gui et vaches et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé après et tout allait très
bien
nous étions très gay s'est sagement de
thé alors nous avons pas mal bu sauf mon
homme qui sous l amour est dans lui elle
aurait aussi bien fait et après après
mais je ne sais pas nous avons continué
à danser
en attendant minuit mais je me souviens
d'elle
[Musique]
m
les emporte tu vas bien connue à l'heure
du chopin
la radio passe moi les chandelles
centaines et nous espérons qu'après
avoir gaiement fini l'année vous
terminerez cette nuit dans la même
atmosphère de joie
ah non surtout pas à l'acheter au prix
empêche le toucher à quoi que ce soit
[Musique]
pourtant dernier mot lui à l'esma fait
un sur deux ne m'aide pas je tiens à
conserver ma main droite comme tu veux
c'est pas toi ce que je pourrais faire
or
pour yves
[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs 10 le
dernier qu'est ce qui était cet après
midi que je suis parvenu à avoir une
fois qu'est ce que c'est baigné accepté
est mort lui même qui se dit frais des
faits justement n'aura pas le temps
d'échanger nos pensées définies pour
l'année nouvelle
échangeons nos verres nos pensées et nos
plus belles années
[Musique]
bon allez on a beaucoup de bonnes choses
des choses que beaucoup de cadeaux
philippe ah oui en fait manas lui gâtés
mois d'août au franc ce sera un test
cadeaux j'ai posé mon verre pour le oui
au qui appelle sa modeste mais c'est
merveilleux
j'ai dû faire une folie écoute ça te
plaît
yann bernard même plutôt faire un cadeau
maintenant cet empire of food riez au
mollet au cou au regard de ce que c'est
joli
[Musique]
merci bernard si j'ai quelque chose pour
toi j'ai cherché le voir mais
entretiennent leurs risques et il a
trouvé
je t'attends parce que ces critères là
il va être ma jambe appareils ça c'est
l'arabe seul dimitri de voir votre pays
bas mot n'a pas dit ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
voilà mon petit c'est ton coeur de la
boire vie voilà
alors ici
à
ces avions
deezer vient c'est idiot j'ai peur c'est
plutôt impressionnant cc crise cardiaque
tu parles mal après le docteur auteuil
17 10 2010
allo auteuil 17 10 je vous ai parlé au
docteur brigneau il faut que je parle d'
acteur lui-même madame c'est personnel
écoutez même je me permettrai pas de
déranger le docteur en plein réveillon à
plus de minuit si ça n'était pas très
urgent merci
[Musique]
merci d'après ce que l'on est de me
raconter la santé les tomber at elle dit
quelque chose
mais vous savez monsieur le commissaire
et on avait déjà eu avant des crises
cardinet va nous verra ça plus tard
le propos inspecteur ou univers dans
lequel l'abus mademoiselle watier ont
trinqué à minuit vous voulez où je sache
oh non plus
là on ne sait même pas où vous avez posé
vos verres vous étiez 4
je viens chacun une coupe de champagne
c'est clair hormis deux là mais on voit
deux autres la cdc de la sspa votre idée
d'échangé ouvert à minuit
je suppose qu'on trouvera les empreintes
de tout le monde donc on en êtes vous
sur philippe a donné notre cadeau à mona
la prier pour l'ouvrir elle est venue
poser son verre là lequel des deux aires
c'est celui là je m'en souviendrai bien
l'autre c'est le mien puis d'ailleurs
c'est évident inspecteurs il ya du rouge
sur celui la passion
je vais mettre une maladie de coeur des
yeux vous rangez tels ces médicaments
alors mois ferme assis dans la salle de
bain c'est au fond du couloir à droite
et la première portait jo je voulais
vous accompagne non merci je te va bien
tout seul soyez sages un une touche est
rien d'ailleurs je suis tranquille si
l'un de vous trois lève le petit doigt
l'un des deux autres viendra me le dire
digitaline bien sûr encore être les
bouteilles soit pas présenté sur un
plateau à les rejettent ils
keller êtes vous arrivés les uns et les
autres pour cette petite réunion amicale
à peu près vers 10h ensemble oui
perron 9h30 vous êtes sûrs de leur a
peut prêt à nous et ils allaient dans la
salle de bain avant la mort de mme
loiselle watier c'est moi qui pose des
questions alors oui la coupure je me
souviens bien vous êtes coupé en
débauchant une bouteille de whisky et de
vodka
si vous voulez vous fait pourquoi pas de
whisky luiz qui s'ouvre s'en tire
bouchon scène locale et dans la salle de
bain et rémy du sparadrap que vous avez
pris dans l'armoire à pharmacie c'est
bien ça vous êtes revenus ensemble au
salon
non moi d'abord pourquoi donc rester
seul dans la salle de bains mais vous
n'êtes pas retourner dans la salle de
bain de toute la soirée
si pour quoi faire pour quoi faire et
vous la salle de bain j'y suis allé ok
pour la raison que mademoiselle vient de
vous exposer comme ça c'est parfait
alors docteur bryant et ses inspecteurs
sommet rit encore moins dans un verre de
faire un vrai réveillon la nuit ou
rentrer à la pétillante et qu'est ce que
vous avez trouvé
c'est un empoisonnement à la digitaline
vous parler c'était remarquez il empeste
encore j'ai pas eu trois pas à faire
dans la salle de bain pour trouver la
bouteille sont encore là 10-3 docteur
aucune chance qu'elle ait pu dépasser la
dose par erreur une chance la digitaline
pour une dose mortelle c'est sans doute
minimum oui évidemment pas question
d'autre chose docteur votre cliente en
plus de sa maladie de coeur elle était
alcoolique
comment pas du tout j'ai trouvé trois
types d'allergies et il doit entamer ce
même pas pour purger les nourrissent en
ont parlé mais comme il ne fallait pas
qu'elle doive d'alcool du tout et
qu'elle pouvait pas s'y résoudre
c'est moi qui lui a ordonné la les
rejettent ils ont d'ailleurs si radicale
vous savez ça ça vous donne des malaises
effroyable des comprend la moindre
goutte alors seulement pour empêcher
l'action l'alcool sur lequel rue et je
dis tu m'as d'acteurs le malaise en
question l'a provoquée par votre truc ça
intervient combien de temps après
l'absorption 5
encore une petite question la verge et
il a t-il un coup quelconque aucun goût
et bien je vous remercie de terre en moi
cette nuit
[Musique]
le soir docteur bon réveillon vous
saviez qu'elle prenait ce médicament
évidemment elle ne s'en cache pas c'est
un ver n'a aucune raison de s'en cacher
elle n'était pas alcoolique comme vous
dites même pas du tout bien philippe
elle nous a dit qu'elle n'avait pas
appris aujourd'hui pour pouvoir boire
avec nous à minuit pauvre mode bon eh
bien je pense maintenant que gâtés moi
ne pouvons plus dire vous être utile et
que nous pouvons partir car oui vous ne
convaincrez par la suite comme témoin si
vous le jugez bon c'est pas que je
tienne absolument d'ailleurs comme
théoule j'ai l'impression d'un petit
bonhomme qu'il faut que jose a franchi
ce qu'est ce qu'on croyait que c'est en
train de faire ici mois une enquête sur
un meurtre vous entendez un meurtre une
femme a été assassinée si cette nuit
elle n'a pu être assassiné par l'un de
vous trois suspects ignoble [ __ ] vous
savez que je ne peux pas vous casser la
gueule parce que vous êtes impliqué e
vous n'attendait que cela
cet emprisonnement ça va vous coûter
cher vous savez que vous n'avez pas de
nous forcer à passer la nuit ici du don
le petit colère et vous êtes bienvenu
ici passer la nuit pour réveillonner un
réveillon a tourné au vinaigre c'est pas
ma faute
moi mais vous la passerez la nuit et
puis vous aussi mopti et vous qu'est ce
que j'avais à dire bien des choses
intolérables parce que je vois que vous
faites votre métier
cette fois vous avez dépassé la dose et
en effet ça pourrait vous coûter cher ah
ouais je ne comprend pas une femme a été
assassinée une femme que vous aimiez que
c'est de savoir qui l'a tué vous ne
désapprouve et comprend pas
bon passons à la suite tout simplement
suicide et susciter mais c'est
intéressant
et pourquoi d'après vous suicidez vous a
parlé de quelque chose non elle avait un
mot ni dans quel ordre sentimentale
jetant quoi je t'en prie
j'imagine que l'inspecteur ne le sera
pas que voulait quitter mona et qu'elle
le savait lle quitter mon époux qui
vouliez vous l'acquittez roma petit vous
cassez pas la tête je peux faire les
demandes les réponses mais où j'ai pas
besoin de vous demander pour qui vous
voulez quitter votre ferr petit hughes
est née sur qui vous aviez tout miser ce
qui fait que vous avez tout perdu comme
un à vous à repousser pas difficile à
comprendre
celui-ci deluna avec sans doute de
digitaline dans un verre de champagne
qui ne s'est pas inversée qu'on lui a
fait boire sans blague
allez maintenant au boulot elle aime
donner votre entrée en vigueur à partir
de midi et je vous préviens qui sera
vérifiée vous monsieur on a seulement un
bref 147 rue lafontaine alors à midi
j'étais toujours à mon usine à chatou 27
rue jean jaurès
j'en suis parti vers 1h je suis allé au
garage pour faire remettre de l'antigel
le garagiste pourra vous dire la marque
à dresde verra dans mon immeuble je suis
allé déjeuner chez ma mère madame
d'oeuvre 43 rue saint jacques
j'en suis parti
vers 5 heures j'ai fait des courses dans
le centre vers 7h30 je suis rentré chez
moi je me suis changé à 9h30 je suis
venu ici à pied à pied oui oui comme
vous l'avez remarqué vous-même j'habite
à côté
125 boulevard berthier les près de la
porte champerret oui à midi j'étais ici
avec mona ici que ce monsieur est venu
faire figurer vous monsieur l'inspecteur
que cela ce fait de venir aider une amie
qui vous reçoit keller êtes vous arrivés
vers 11 heures
nous sommes descendu acheter tout ce
qu'il fallait et puis nous avons
travaillé et keller et de vos parties à
5 heures jade sur absolument à cinq ans
et demi j'étais au magasin de philippe
et nous nous sommes plus quitté jusqu'à
notre arrivée ici
donc à partir de 5h30 votre emploi du
temps correspond à 20 minutes philippe
oui merci philippe gaubrie laiss ait les
accents graves s 125 boulevard berthier
story 5 c'est la même adresse
ah oui vous êtes filles et ensuite pour
moi inspecteurs c'est extrêmement simple
31 décembre c'est pratiquement notre
plus gros jour de vente alors je n'ai
pas quitté le magasin jusqu'à 5h30
adresse philippe gauthier 18 rue boissy
d'anglas ce à 5h30 huguette est venu me
chercher
nous sommes allés ensemble au cinéma
quel film quelle salle au colisée
nathalie ensuite nous sommes rentrés
boulevard berthier nous nous sommes
changé et nous sommes venus directement
ici en voiture vers 10 heures merci
en somme aucun de vous ne se trouvait
ici vers sept heures du soir
bon je crois que nous approchons du but
me serais peut-être pas forcés de passer
la nuit ici si vous fabriquez je peux
prendre un verre mais oui mon petit
remonté où c'est le moment pour mettre
les choses bien au pont vais répéter les
quelques minutes qui ont précédé la mort
de mademoiselle watier vous me direz si
vous êtes bien d'accord pose y est à
minuit juste vous est venu tous les
quatre un quai exactement à
l'emplacement je me trouve c'est bien ça
comme ça bon qui avait rempli les verts
si je me souviens bien c'est philip wee
qui les a portés j'en ai porté 2 1 pour
mana et un port et guette mais c'est
bernard qui a porté le mit en même temps
que le ciel et vous avez changé vos
verres mazel watier après une verdict
qui le mien je vous jure que je n'ai pas
tué je vous le jure
j'en voulais d'accord mais jamais je
l'aurai ce qui comprend un jeu n'est pas
encore accusé n'ont alors pas avoir but
est de donner des cadeaux tombés tout à
coup vous êtes tous précipités et à ce
moment vous étiez là et où vous étiez là
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est ce qui ne m'apportait quand elle
est tombée elle n'a pas eu le temps de
me donner je lui porte clés de voiture
vous permettez
merci
c'était donc bien vos places à saint
marin et vous vous utile encore une
question vous êtes allé faire des achats
le matin avec mademoiselle watier
qu'elle avait pris sa voiture
moi n'avaient pas de voiture elle avait
bien trop la frousse de conduire la
pauvre merci il va je considère mon
enquête comme terminée le meurtrier l'un
de vous trois et je sais lequel ou
laquelle et vous savez vous qui a tué
vous avez eu les mêmes un disque mois
pour parvenir à la solution
vous avez vu les mêmes images vous avez
entendu les mêmes paroles au cas où vous
hésiteriez encore nous alors passé dans
mon bureau vous ai convoqué deux experts
qui nous donneront leur avis vous ne
pouvez pas le rappeur besoin de vous
oui j'ai fait vite pour venir de la rue
toussaint à la pj sont les mystères de
la télévision nous allons maintenant
introduire nos experts entre et
messieurs je vous prie asseyez-vous
je me permets de tout d'abord de vous
présenter aux téléspectateurs
d'abord monsieur charest ce monsieur
chéres je crois nous est un grand
amateur de romans policiers nous enliser
beaucoup n'auraient pas jusqu'à dire que
vous lisez tous ma faim presque presque
oui alors vous êtes préféré sur la
question et vous débrouiller une énigme
policière
comme qui rigole vous flatter une
sélection des pierres a pesté gym suivi
a investi 10 il est un auteur de romans
policiers
monsieur pères a pesté guillaume tell
dans les deux romans d'aventurés à fond
son roman le roi des singes également
l'auteur de l'amdh 11h du chail clair de
lune le scénariste de nathalie le film
qui passe actuellement dont il est le co
auteur sous le monde de frank marshall
c'est bien c'est vrai que mes
renseignements souvent où il serait
alors vous avez assisté à l'émission
vous avez vu je pense que vous êtes fait
une opinion est que vous avez un
coupable me proposer mais je ne voudrais
pas que vous me donniez le nom de
contact je suis tombé dedans c'est x
parce que ceci parce que cela je
voudrais que vous me disiez quels sont
les séquences quels sont les scènes qui
ont pu éveiller vos soupçons et vous
mettre sur la voie alors nous vous
montrerons ces séquences et le temps
nous est très limité et là je ne peux
vous accorder à chacun que 6 minutes 30
pour découvrir les coupables et me
donner la possibilité de revoir deux
séquences jeu charasse niveau
d'intervention parle ou via oui j'ai
pris quelques notes l'ap j'aimerais
beaucoup revoir la séquence où l'on
procède à un échange des verts dans le
sable aux français d'aller charge des
verts mais c'est bien facile nous allons
vous montrer ça immédiatement
et pendant ce temps vous demandez vous
[Musique]
et vous acceptez bernanke est ce que tu
fais dépêche-toi n'aura pas le temps
d'échanger nos pensées les fini pour les
immigrés les chansons ouvert nos pensées
et nos vies
[Musique]
bonne année
lehman a surtout beaucoup de cadeaux ah
oui tiens mal à juliette et moi nous
tenons ce modeste cadeau
j'ai posé mon verre oui qu'est ce que
c'est
surprise
j'aimerais si c'est possible revoir la
séquence trou munadi avait tel point de
la large estime mme najet qu'elle prend
mal et rejettent ils c'est à dire après
l'histoire de mets pas tous ses services
c'est bien facile nous allons vous
montrer ça immédiatement
[Musique]
tu pourras partir en bateau si longtemps
fait de maladies de coeur et vous avez
en rien ça va beaucoup mieux depuis que
je me prive de boire et fumer de voir au
minéral à la moindre petite étincelle
régime
ce soir minuit
nous croyons outre que l'allergie gilles
lalay rejettent ils l'allergie t-il
ça ne plante pas dans des états
épouvantable que tu bois d'alcool
naturellement c'est pour ça que j'en
pense me suis abstenu aujourd'hui tu as
l'air aussi mauvais état ces dernières
années je ne vais pas ménagé leurs
efforts c'est de vivre comme une petite
vieille 10 dont je n'ai pas 100 ans
nous on vient suivre je ne suis pas une
petite fille monté en graine moi c'est
pour moi que je connais au moins un
homme qui préfère une vieille peau comme
moi la paix de franchise
cet homme dont tu parles il est ici tu
peux le nommé par pitié pas vide et on
est ici pour réveillonner gentiment pas
pour son gré
bon je charge de séquences sur merci
monsieur p sting quelle séquence des
regrets pour avoir je voudrais d'abord
voir la séquence à la salle de bains ou
huguette retrouve le médicament que le
recherche pour soigner ces séquences par
abraham la séquence b l'otan de mener
jusqu'à celle de monde c'est pas loin ça
peut lui être fait tout de suite
[Musique]
retrouver quelque chose dans un désordre
pareil il ya tout là dedans sauf du
sparadrap un vrai désordre la mona à
donne moi ta main attends je les suis je
là recolle
voilà tu peux aller faire le beau salon
matin
voilà c'est plus qu'un véhicule entre
deuxième séquence alors je voudrais voir
la séquence qui passe est le moment où
il ya des changes des verts se dire
quand les deux hommes verse le champagne
dans des équipes de rôle ces camps ce
qui précède il sait que vous nous voir
tout à l'heure vous avez demandé
monsieur charge pas le temps de revenir
dans le living room
nous y sommes
[Musique]
alors chers lumineuse
toujours l'an dernier mot pas joli
laisse moi faire et surtout ne m'aide
pas je tiens à conserver ma main droite
comme tu veux c'est pas toi ce que je
pourrais faire pour vous pourrir
[Musique]
[Rires]
dit qu'est ce que tu lui offre à bernard
pour n'en parle pas c'est seulement cet
après midi je suis parvenu à ce que
c'est surprise mais la baie ignorez vous
acceptez sa part est maintenant
qu'est-ce que tu ferais dépêche-toi
n'aura pas le temps additionnel on
l'entend la formule de d'été est finie
parodiant le héros voit les nouvelles
échangeons nos verres nos pensées et nos
voeux
[Musique]
bonne année
julie pas alors monsieur ferrasse votre
comptable penser que c'est philippe
c'est philippe bon monsieur l'abbé
stiggy je pense que c'est bernard penser
que c'est vers la rue alors je vais vous
présenter le coupable
rappelez moi et je ne vous en dis quand
même vous présenter au mieux gardiens
voulait voir nulle prisonniers nous
avons au clip et bernard huguet tort de
vous voilà que cheikh coupable et devra
vivre en survêt c'est en effet vers
l'art monsieur avait été dit vous avez
raison
comment avez vous trouvé eh bien il
était impossible que le que la personne
qui a porté le vert à philippe dans
sachant qu'il allait le donnait à hugues
à tout ne soit pas l'assassin parce que
soit qu'il voulait tuer le rival exécré
à cause duquel il pensait que sa femme
ne l'aimé plus soit qui veulent s'en
débarrasser il peut avoir tué sa femme
qu'il aimait plus en avoir c'est exprès
en voulant que son camarade ou l'avoir
fait exprès en sachant qu'il allait
faire des changes des verts mais dans
les deux cas celui c'était effectivement
le vie mais c'est bien sa femme qui
voulait lui il a bien réussi à fait non
sa femme et sa maîtresse pour s'en
débarrasser est-ce qu'il est amoureux
fou c'était dangereux parce que j'aurais
pu ne pas faire les changes d'evel
avancer votre choix fallu tellement des
changes devait il a eu juste réponse il
ne vous avez vous n'avez pas vu très
exactement ce qui s'est passé alors si
vous le permettez je vais voir montrer
la séquence qui aurait dû vous faire
trouver il ya un autre petit élément je
vous indiquerai après vous voulez donner
la séquence
merci
oui c'est bien bernard cette séquence
[Musique]
aux oies coudrier ces baby joly merci
verna aussi j'ai quelque chose pour toi
elle est versée montreuil et keller
s'ajouter la rhapsodie c'est dommage
bernard ou est-ce que tu l'as trouvé au
gb ii mais j'avais appareils voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe
voilà ce qu'il fasse ce qui t'arrive
voilà on a cette enquête dans la boire
vite pourquoi
il
mais
deezer mieux qu'à man s'évalue si diouf
m'a dit tu vas pas nous faire ça un
premier gros billets qu'est-ce qui se
passe à peine le docteur breniaux
auteuil 17 10 2010
vous avez vu bernard maître la
digitaline dans le vert laissez le verre
plein sur la table et lorsqu'il a dit à
philippe de l'avoir à vonnas philippe
automatiquement s'est emparé du verglas
et la porter à mona qui a vu la
digitaline et comme le comprimé de la
verge et il qu'elle avait pris dans la
journée à son insu est bernard était
venu l'après midi il fait prendre de la
verge et il se comprimer l'avait mis
dans un état pathologique de quasi
inconscient ce qui fait qu'elle n'a pas
senti le mauvais goût de la digitaline
voilà je vous disais qu'il ya un autre
élément et moi c'est celui qui m'a mis
sur la voie ce sont les clés de la
voiture
les clés sont dont le porte clés que
mona lui offert et ce sont les clés de
la voiture de bernard puisque mona n'a
pas de voiture
comment mona at elle pu se procurer les
clés de voiture de bernard elle les lui
a subtilisé un moment vous l'été
certaines qui n'en avait pas besoin
donc c'est quand il est venu l'après
midi
sa voiture était devant suivi au garage
elle savait qu'ils s'en servirait pas
puisqu'il irait chez lui changer et
reviendrait pour réveillonner il habite
à côté donc il fait le chemin à pied à
ce moment-là lui emprunte ses écrits
pour être certaine que les clés irait
bien dans le porte clés parce qu'il ya
des clés de voiture que les tout petits
trous il s'adapte qui ne s'adaptent pas
surtout les porte-clés c'est à ce moment
là qu'elle lui a fait signer c'est donc
il est vu l'après-midi ce qui ne fait
aucun doute il était clair également
l'autre pensait qu'il avait pas par
esprit maintenant les premiers à oui oui
c'est impossible vraiment il a eu trois
possibilités de la tuer c'est pour ça
que j'ai cru que tant sur les trois
tasses ming
il y avait encore une chose qui aurait
pu lui faire trouver mais dès le début
alors je vous le dis parce que dès le
début dans le générique de riez pu
trouver puisque nous autres titres été
la clé de l'énigme
[Musique]
bon
et
m
ah bon
après
là
[Musique]